Well, hey, if you've been tracking along with the Olympics, then you know the games ended in stunning fashion this past Sunday.
Some of you know what I'm talking about for others of you though.
You may be uninformed.
So let me do you a great kindness in informing you.
The US men's hockey team.
One gold in stellar fashion.
Stellar fashion because this is the first gold medal we've picked up in the last
46 years, yes, you heard me, right?
The last 46 years, yes, it has been roughly half a century since we found ourselves in the gold medal match.
We were then at that time accustomed to people like Coach Herb Brooks and all those young boys that performed the miracle on ice as we took on the undefeatable Soviet Union, and yet we did the impossible then.
Wouldn't you know we did the impossible
Again, but that's not the only thing that's amazing about this last weekend.
It's not just that we won gold after 46 years.
It's also the way in which we won gold in overtime.
And what was just a little over a minute when all hope seemed lost.
One young man by the name of Jack Hughes decided to take matters into his own hands and seal the deal and score the golden gold.
for our country.
It was an amazing event.
And yet, though it is remarkable that Jack Hughes did this, it's also remarkable to know that he wasn't alone.
Jack is one of two brothers that plays on the US men's hockey team.
His brother Quinn Hughes also serves on the hockey team as a defenseman.
And so when I learned that he wasn't alone, that Quinn is in there as well, I had to ask the question, how is Quinn dealing with all of this?
Baby brother swoops in, it steals the glory for himself.
And I was shocked to find as is much of the country that Quinn, who is such a class act, has just expressed the utmost admiration and pride towards his brother.
He said this in an interview.
He said, I'm just so proud of him.
People have no idea how hard this journey has been for him.
Dealing with injuries and battling through so much to be the player that he is, he's one of the best players in the world and I'm so glad that everybody got to see why today.
He's just a dog.
And a post later on that he commented after sharing it alongside Sports Center and ESPN, he simply said one word.
to surmise his thoughts around his brother, Jack.
And it was beneath this photo that he said, hero.
You see, our nation has been stunned since Sunday, not just because the US men's hockey team did something that was unimaginable.
They stepped in and they won gold.
Yes, that is so shocking.
But we have also been shocked by the way in which Quinn has responded to the success of his brother.
He has been a class act, as I've already said, and yet at the same time, what we know is this has got to be hard.
Like all of us are reading through the comments and trying to ascertain, man, what do we all really think about this?
Because, man, when you are arguably the more decorated skater, you are the older brother, and yet your brother has swept in and he has stolen the glory.
How are you dealing with that?
And yet as he has responded so admirably, it has left the nation speechless.
We're trying to reckon with how one man could respond in the way in which he has, because we know this
would be difficult.
And the reason we know it is because we've lived it.
We've found ourselves in positions where we're looking at our own set of circumstances, and we've evaluated differently than he did.
We've evaluated, this isn't fair.
This feels crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
I'm totally misunderstood.
Things didn't play out the way that I thought.
You see, according to one study by the Edelman Trust Barometer, which evaluates fairness and opportunity in the United States,
Catch this, 83%, that would be the vast majority of our room.
Eight out of 10 of you, young adults, 18 to 34-year-olds reported feeling subjected to unfair treatment in some way in their life.
Feeling discriminated against, whether it's at work or it's in their social sphere or it's in the marketplace in some way, which is something we all understand because whether you're working hard,
You still can't afford rent or you're reminded via social media often that outcomes in other people's lives rarely actually match their effort or you and your ex have very different responses after the breakup.
They're thriving while you're still healing or you're just quietly quitting on the job because your boss overworks you but undervalues you.
We can't help but agree with what that great 21st century philosopher, Olivia Rodrigo said.
God, it's brutal out here.
In a study, ABC News found that only 21% of US adults believe in the American dream.
21%.
It has stunned researchers to hear our generation lean in and say, that doesn't feel legitimate any longer.
So as they've tried to make reason as to why we think the American dream is in fact just a dream, they have asked us and what we have said in response is that idealized life.
just is not fair.
It feels unrealistic because life is unrealistic.
Life is unfair.
It doesn't matter if you want to call it burnout, if you want to call it hard mode, if you want to call it character development, if you want to call it late stage capitalism, or if you just want to believe that the algorithm hates you, everyone is saying the same thing just through different words.
We think life is not fair, which is easier to accept if
You don't believe in God.
And you just think that everything that's happening around you is the accidental byproduct of some random processes, but it is much more difficult if you do believe in God.
Because you know nothing is accidental.
Everything is purposeful.
That there is a sovereign supreme, a creator of the cosmos.
That this God whom we say we believe in is supposed to be the giver of every good and perfect gift.
And yet as we look at the world around us and we consider the life that we live, we know something just doesn't make sense.
And it's not just that life doesn't feel fair.
It's that he doesn't feel fair.
What do you do with that?
Well, that's what Genesis 4 is all about.
So if you have a Bible, you can grab it.
You can turn with me to Genesis chapter 4.
If this is your first time to the porch, welcome.
We're so glad you're here.
We've been working through a series in the book of Genesis where we're looking at 10 of the most iconic stories found within its pages.
And the reason why is we want to
acquaint ourselves, for many of us reacquaint ourselves with who God is.
And as we study this first book in the Bible, we see each of these stories telling us different aspects of our Lord.
And as we come to this story, we find ourselves, and yet again, another familiar one.
We find ourselves looking at the story of Cain and Abel.
This is the first sibling rivalry in human history.
I don't know how you feel about your siblings, but these guys had some beef.
And as we look,
is that many of us approach this story with a different perspective.
Some of you, you've read this story, you're actually really familiar with it, and so you approach it systematically.
You theologically unpack and think through the essence of total depravity that is expressed by way of its pages.
Others of you, you're vaguely familiar.
You know the broad strokes, and you know that this story lines up like some sort of ancient Near Eastern soap opera.
One brother kills another brother, and you're not real sure what happened, but man,
as goes and all God's children.
Others of you, you think about this story and what comes to mind when you think of Cain and Abel is what came to mind in the mind of one of my staff people, which is raising Cain's.
Which interestingly is a phrase of speech that finds its historical origin in Cain and Abel, but we won't go there for now.
What you need to understand is that though we all read this story and hear something different, many of us, most of us, do not hear our story.
when we read Cain's story.
The reason why is because it just feels so unrelatable.
It feels even primeval.
It doesn't feel practical in the slightest because he's a murderer and I'm not.
And yet here's what I would argue with you because, as already said, I'm coming in as someone that has been touched by this text myself.
This story, it isn't just Cain's story.
It's our.
story.
And I want us to read it as such because what we're going to find as we read through this is we're going to see that his story, our story, is one that speaks to this really unfair fact that God himself at times doesn't feel fair.
So what are we doing?
That's the case.
That's what I want to tell you.
So let's just look at it.
We're going to go a little by little and we're going to talk.
Verse 1, Now Adam do Eve his wife.
And she conceived and she bore Cain saying, I've gotten a man with the help of the Lord.
And again, she bore his brother Abel.
Now Abel was a keeper of sheep and Cain a worker of the ground.
And in the course of time Cain brought to the Lord an offering of the fruit of the ground.
And Abel also brought of the first born of his flock.
and of their fat portions.
Now, we'll just stop there because we need to understand something important about this text.
Namely, before we get to any of the conflict, we need to understand the characters.
We just met several, but there's two that we want to zoom in on.
We want to zoom in on these two brothers, Cain and Abel.
What we know is that Cain is the older of the two brothers, which in the ancient Near East would actually come with it.
Many important would come with it.
Much significant detail.
What we know as a first born in their culture is that Cain would have really two privileges.
Number one, he would be
the primary beneficiary of his family's inheritance.
In the number two, we would know that he is the representative male head in place of his father, should his father pass, or his father's just absent.
He would become the representative head of the family, ensuring the family's legacy.
You see, Cain is sort of like the first Nepo baby ever.
He had it easier than most everybody else.
It was just his by way of birthright.
He was the guy that you knew in high school that everybody loved to hate.
He had ridiculous genes.
He played varsity when nobody else did.
He never studied, but always seemed to make straight A's.
He was a foot taller than the rest of us.
I don't have any bitterness you do.
And yet what we know is that regardless that it may have been God-given, he nonetheless deserved to be respected.
He deserved to be honored and he deserved to be privileged.
It's just by way of who he was.
And yet therein lies the first lesson you must know if you want to understand why God feels unfair at times.
You have to know God feels unfair at times when we focus too much on what we deserve and too little on what God deserves.
God will feel unfair.
when you focus too much on what you deserve and too little on what he deserves.
We can tell that this is the case just by way of looking at their offerings in contrast to one another.
You see, Cain,
He brings what the text says is an offering of the fruit of the ground, which is a legitimate offering.
He brings what Leviticus 2 tells us is a serial or a grain offering.
And yet what's really unique about grain offerings is they're unlike any other offering in Leviticus.
We know that they're not bound by strict rigid, they're not bound by rigidity or rules.
There's some flexibility in how you can actually express this offering because it was considered a free will offering.
The thought there being that you could offer to God
What she wanted, however much she wanted, which should beg a question in our mind, okay?
Well, then how much did Cain actually want to give to God?
He gives an indistinct bundle of produce.
It's legitimate, but it's not very detailed.
Whereas in contrast, we look at Abel who brought the first born of his flock and their fat portions.
Do you see the difference?
There's just more detail.
He gives the first born of his flock.
Like he gives the strength of those little Lamys.
He raised of the very first one, that one which would have been useful for resourcing, for wool and for mating and eventually for food.
He takes it and he offers it to God and he gives to God the fat portions, like that most nourishing and precious part of the animal.
He offers it to God.
He doesn't show up to God and offer him a USDA select sirloin.
He says, hey, you know what?
I've got the wagyu ribeye.
Here you go, God.
He offers him the very best thing that he can because God likes that cut.
And what we see
is that God has favor for Abel by way of what he offers.
I love the way that Richard Hess says it.
He says, by giving the firstborn and the best of the animal, the fat, Abel would be understood as having given everything to God.
Do you see it?
Cain gives something to God, while Abel gives everything to God.
And here's the lesson that you need to know.
You can tell a lot about the offeror by way of their offering.
I learned this lesson very plainly just two weeks ago when I and every other husband in DFW arose at the crack of dawn and visited a local grocery store because it was Valentine's Day and we needed to buy our wives flowers.
It's quite the sight.
It's just a bunch of men walking around the floral department trying to pick out whatever they think their wife might like.
And as I'm there, I run into a guy that goes to church here at Watermark.
And so we strike up a conversation and ask him, hey, man, what's the plan for the day?
And he looks at me with all of his kids in tow.
And he says, well, we've already sent Mama for a little bit of a spa day, give her a little bit of me time.
And me and the kids are getting her some flowers.
And we're going to go make some homemade Valentine's cards.
And as he said this to me, I thought to myself, that's a man that knows what his woman loves because the offering says a lot about the offeror.
So let me ask you this, what are you offering to God?
What are you offering to him?
Would you offer him today?
Would you offer him this week?
What did you offer him with respect to your time?
Like did you give him your time just whenever it was convenient?
Or did you give him your time whenever it wasn't convenient?
When it came to the scripture, did you take the easy route and let someone else explain to you whatever it is that God might have said?
Or did you go the hard route, study them on your own, meditate even when it was difficult because you don't want to hear what someone has to say.
God might have said, you want to hear what he has to say himself.
What about prayer?
Did you treat prayer like it's just the last resort?
Or did you treat prayer like it was the first response whenever that thing happened this week, that problem popped up out of nowhere, whatever trouble seemed to arise and you did not know what to do.
Did you pray as your first response?
Do you walk into rooms like this and different about the thought of meeting with God?
Or do you walk into rooms like this expectant that God wants to meet with you?
Do you worship?
This might be too personal.
Do you worship in a way where all of your attention is just about you?
I don't want to stand out.
I don't want to sound weird.
I don't want to look bad.
Or do you worship in a way where all of your attention is about him?
What are you offering to God?
How much?
Are you offering to God?
Abel?
Abel brings the first fruit.
He brings the very best of what he has to give.
He gives the fat portion to God because he knows God is worth everything and we have to know the same thing.
You see, here's the problem.
Often we accuse God of not being fair to us when we are guilty of not being fair to him.
You tracking with that?
Like we often look at God and we're like, where are you at God?
You're not being fair to me.
And yet the reality is, if we look at our time, we examine our calendar, we pay attention to our transactions, we would realize we're the ones that's not being fair to him.
We would offer him something when he actually deserves everything.
That's what we see all throughout the scripture.
Revelation 4, 11 says, worthy are you a Lord and God to receive glory and honor and power for you created all things and by your will.
They existed and were created.
Do you hear it?
1 Timothy 1, 17, now to the king eternal, immortal, invisible, the only God be honored and glory forever and ever.
Amen.
Romans 11, 36, for from him and through him and to him are all things, to him and him alone.
be glory forever and ever amen.
Are you tracking with what this is saying?
So why then, Christian, if you are a member of the family of God, if you identify as a follower of Jesus, if you believe these things are true, why is it that you're living with a calculated devotion?
Were you give to God some part of yourself, maybe even most of yourself, but you don't give to God every part of yourself.
You think Christ went to the cross just to die for some part of you?
No, Christ went to the cross to die for every part of you.
And the reason we know that is because he didn't just give up some part of himself, he gave up all of himself.
If that's the case, if he would willingly offer all of himself to you, why then can we not offer all of ourself to him in return?
This is the issue we think God is unfair when we, in fact, are unfair because the fairest thing we could do
is give him everything we've got.
That's your first point.
Second, we find in verse four.
And the Lord had regard for Abel and his offering.
But for Cain and his offering, he had no regard.
So Cain was very angry in his face fell.
The Lord said, Cain, why are you angry?
Why is your face fallen?
If you do well, will you not be accepted?
And if you do not do well, sin is crouching at the door.
It's desires for you.
and you must rule over it.
So both Cain and Abel, they bring offerings to God, yes?
And yet what we just saw is that God only regards Abel's offering.
It's kind of a weird word, right?
God regarded.
Well, if you look in the Hebrew, the idea behind that word regarded is he looked or he gazed upon, not just the offering, he actually gazes upon Abel and Abel's offering, which feels unfair.
Because again, Cain first born.
And so his responsibility as one of the representative heads of the family is to present offerings to God as his father would.
And yet here's Abel doing the same thing.
And it's Abel that God seems to regard.
He's the one that he looks at.
But Cain isn't.
That feels so unfair of God.
And yet we have to ask the question, then was there something wrong with Cain's offering?
No.
Again,
Cain's offering is totally suitable.
It's a serial offering.
It's a grain offering.
It's perfectly legit to give to God.
It doesn't mean that there was something wrong with Cain's offering, but catch this, it does mean that there was something right about Abel's offering.
So several years ago, Brooke and I, we were in Florence, Italy, and we were walking through the academia gallery.
If you're familiar with the academia, then what you know is most people go to the academia not to see all of the marble sculptures that they have littered across their premises.
And they are incredible sculptures within their own right.
But people don't go there for all the myriad of other sculptures.
They go there for one sculpture and one sculpture alone.
They go there for Michelangelo's David.
And it's not because the other sculptures are bad.
The other sculptures are good.
But David is better.
You see, David is greater than the rest because though they are good, he is great.
And that's what's happening here.
You see, Cain has not been rejected by God in this moment.
Abel is merely being favored by God in this moment.
And yet, in this moment, Cain experiences the entirety of what's happening
as personal rejection.
That's why comparison is so very, that's why comparison is so very costly because Cain doesn't realize what we need to realize that favor for somebody else does not mean disfavor for you.
Favor for somebody else does not mean disfavor for you.
That was Cain's experience.
It says that he grew angry and his face dropped.
I love that.
Like you can just picture what's happening to him.
That idea, he grew angry.
It's the thought of him getting heated anger.
Like his blood starts to boil.
He gets hot is what happens.
And then it says that his face drops, like his face falls.
And yet what's happening is you see those two images like a little kid who crosses his arms and ducks his head and starts muttering under his breath.
What we realize is two things are true of him.
In this moment, he is both vindictive and he is victimized.
Which is a really potent mix because what it tells us is he feels like he didn't get what he deserved.
And he's willing to do something about it.
He's willing to take action to honor the injustice he feels like he has suffered.
That's what makes comparison so dangerous because often we internalize somebody else's success as our own personal failure.
And yet that's just not true.
Like just because somebody gets promoted doesn't mean that your boss hates you.
Just because you have a friend who starts dating somebody doesn't mean that nobody wants you.
Just because you see somebody succeed doesn't mean that they're a threat to you.
Just because you're scrolling through Instagram a little bit too long and you realize that everybody's moving ahead doesn't mean that you're left behind.
What we do is we in the process of comparing we often find ourselves growing in resentment.
What's resentment?
Reseminent is not just wanting what other people have, it's hating them for having it.
And yet comparison often breeds this type of response.
That's what the author of Hebrew writes.
He writes in Hebrews chapter 12, strive for peace with everyone and for the holiness without which no one will see the Lord.
See to it that no one fails to obtain the grace of God, that no root of bitterness springs up and causes trouble.
and by it many become defiled.
What's the author saying?
He's saying that our issue is not the fruit of resentment.
What they have, how much they have, what they achieve, what you can't seem to.
Our issue is not the fruit of resentment, it's the root of resentment.
And when we evaluate the root of resentment, what we need to know is that our issue is not with anybody else,
Our issue is with God.
That's the truth of it.
If you find yourself boiling and brooding because they've got something that you think you deserve, your issue is not with them.
Your issue is with Him.
You see, that's what we realize as we study through this thing.
We realize that Cain feels like many of us do.
He feels cheated.
He feels mistreated.
He feels underappreciated.
Anybody ever felt like that?
Here's the crazy thing about it.
God is actually the only one that has been cheated.
He is the only one that has been mistreated.
He is the only one that has been underappreciated because he is the only one worthy of anything.
That's the great irony here.
We feel disfavored by God.
when God has been disfavored by us.
That's what Romans 3 tells us in verses 11, 12.
It says, none is righteous.
No, not one.
No one understands.
No one seeks for God.
All have turned aside together.
They have become worthless.
No one does good, not even one.
Don't you see?
Like we turn our backs on God.
We turned our back on God before the thought ever even crossed our mind that he might have turned his back on us.
So how does he respond to us when we do that to him?
Does he smite us where we stand?
Does he render judgment from afar?
Does he condemn you to hell with no hope at all?
No.
I love it.
His response in this story is the same response that he had in the last story.
He just starts asking questions.
In the past, anything is, he just starts asking questions that he already knows the answers to.
But we ourselves have not yet answered.
So what are the questions?
He looks at Cain.
And friend, I think he's looking at you.
And he's asking you, why are you angry?
Why are you angry?
Is it because you didn't get what you thought you deserved?
Is it because someone achieved that thing that you wanted?
Is it because you feel like life's been unfair?
Maybe it's not why are you angry.
Maybe it's why is your face fallen?
Why are you so downcast?
Do you fear that you'll never be happy?
Do you fear that I've forgotten you?
Do you fear that I don't hear your prayers when they rise up to heaven?
Do you fear that this is all there will ever be for you?
The amazing thing about this story is it communicates to us the character and nature of God as we learn that God comes to us the same way He came to Cain.
He comes reaching out, wanting to process and talk through it all.
He comes asking questions and ultimately affirming for us that there is still favor for you too.
This is the thing that wrecked me.
because it is so easy in our modern age to look left and right and see what everybody else has and wonder why God would do that for them but not do it for us.
And if the truth of this story is saying, he's got plenty to give.
He literally, he says to Cain, he says, if you do well, will you not be accepted?
You see, he's communicating, hey, bro, I've got favor to spare.
I've got an inexhaustible well of blessing.
So why are you worried?
Why are you stressed?
Why are you resentful?
Why do you envy?
I've got everything and more that you could want.
So, hey, you didn't do it today.
That's okay.
Let's try again tomorrow.
Let's try again the next day.
Let's not give up right now.
Let's just continue to go.
Let's keep on walking.
Let's keep on talking.
Let's keep on processing.
Let's not give up on the fact that there is favor enough for you all.
God's position towards us as is true for Cain.
It never changed.
Like we don't deserve it, but a loving God is still beckoning and unlovely people to repent and come home.
We don't deserve it, but a forgiving God is still seeking an unforgivable people because he can call them to forgiveness and bring them into right relationship.
We don't deserve it, but Christ, the favorable has laid down his life for the unfavorable that we might receive blessing from God again.
You see, God's position towards us has not changed.
Let me just ask you then, has yours?
If his position hasn't changed, if he looks at you and he loves you and he accepts you and he values you and he wants you, what's your position have to say in response?
It's crazy.
We see in the story that though God's position towards Cain has not changed,
Cain's position towards God has changed.
That's what we pick up as we keep reading.
Look at verse 8, Cain spoke to Abel as brother.
And when they were in the field, Cain rose up against his brother, Abel, and he killed him.
Then the Lord said to Cain, where is Abel your brother?
That interesting.
It's the same question he asked Eve in the last chapter.
He says, what have you done?
The same question he asked Eve in the last chapter.
The voice of your brother's blood is crying to me from the ground.
And now you're cursed from the ground, which has opened its mouth to receive your brother's blood from your hand.
When you work the ground, it'll no longer yield to you at strength.
You shall be a fugitive.
A wanderer on the earth.
And so Cain said to the Lord, my punishment, it's greater than I can bear.
Behold, you've driven me today away from the ground.
And from your face, I shall be hidden.
I'll be a fugitive.
And a wanderer on the earth, whoever finds me, they're going to kill me.
This story, it's so tragic for me.
Because as I read it, I see something that I think we'd often miss.
You see, if we were to ask people, just the general public, hey, what's the story of Cain and Abel about?
Most people would look at us and they would just say, murder.
It's about murder.
One guy killed his brother.
And they wouldn't be wrong because this is the first recorded murder in human history.
We see Cain rise up and strike his brother down.
And yet what's fascinating about it is it takes all of one sentence to explain that specific detail.
But there are 20 sentences here over, over viewing this account of Cain's life.
But one sentence given to murder.
I'm not much of a true crime podcast guy, but that doesn't make for a really compelling arc.
Like we don't see him concoct some maniacal plan.
We don't see him brandish, some sort of murder weapon.
He doesn't hide a body or flee the scene.
He just looks at his brother and is like, hey man, you want to go for a walk?
Bam, like it's over.
You know, like that's all it takes for the murder to take place.
And yet it begs the question for us then, if that's true, what is this about?
I think it's about rivalry.
I think this story is about rivalry.
Two people competing in pursuit of the same goal.
And you want to know why I think that's so very tragic.
Because that which came wanted for the smile of God was not something he could earn.
Because you can't earn what you already have.
But it is something you can lose.
And he does.
and we did.
All of us, like sheep have gone astray, each of us by way of our sin are subject to death.
We have committed a criminal offense of our own, not murder like this, but we have committed that crime of sinning against a holy God, and therefore his right response to us is not unfairness, but fairness.
because you may not think that God always gives you what you deserve, but third point, God always gives sin what it deserves.
God always gives sin what it deserves.
There are so many ironies in this story.
I had to keep myself from writing.
Isn't it ironic?
Because they're just all over the place, man.
Like this whole story is one giant irony.
But I think maybe the biggest one is that Cain's problem with God's unfairness and blessing ables actions
is actually overcome by God's fairness in condemning his own.
Like, here's the thing, despite what we might feel about being, about God being unfair or him being unjust or him being prejudiced against us, what we must know that the scriptures declare loud and clear is God is fair.
He is fair.
He will deal with all sin, whether it is now or it is later.
We know.
He is not patient as some count patients, but he is desiring that all would come to the knowledge of his repentance.
That's what 2 Peter 3 tells us.
We know he's holy, he's righteous, he's just, and because that is true, he will not overlook a single offense.
Doesn't matter how small, nor how big it is, every single offense is worthy of the same condemnation in that we have sinned against him.
And here's why that's such a hard truth.
There's no dealing with sin without dealing with us.
Ephesians 2 verse 3 says, all of us lived among them at one time gratifying the cravings of our flesh and following its desires and thoughts like the rest of them.
We were by nature deserving of wrath.
Some translations say we are children of wrath.
which feels so hard to read.
If you're here for the first time, this can feel tough to stomach.
And yet if it is, it means that we probably have an improper understanding of what wrath actually is.
You see, wrath is not the opposite of love, as our world would say.
Wrath is an expression of love in that
It is loving to destroy that which seeks to hurt what you care about most.
I never understood this more clearly than until I stood in a hospital room and I held my little 8-pound, 8-ounce baby boy in my hands.
I learned a lot about myself in that moment.
I learned the depth to which I could love someone that never did anything for me.
And I also learned the links to which I would go.
to protect him from anyone that would dare harm him.
In that hospital room, I learned a lot about wrath, which is not wrong of God to feel.
It is right of God to feel.
That's why Cain is freaking out in this moment.
He realizes like the rest of us, he is sinned against God, and he is deserving of his wrath.
He wanted God to treat him fairly, and the minute God does, he cannot handle it.
He literally says, my punishment is greater than I can bear.
Behold, you've driven me today away from the ground.
Your face from me shall now be hidden.
Do you hear the panic?
He literally, he says, I've been driven from the ground.
That is so sad because what it tells us is Cain has just in this moment been robbed of his purpose.
Again, mankind's God-given purpose as we see in Genesis 1 and Genesis 2 is that they would work the ground.
that they would order chaos, that they would produce flourishing.
And yet he just realized his sin is going to oppose his very own purpose.
He says that he has been hidden from God's face, meaning he has been removed from God's presence.
That was never the intent.
We see that God would walk in the cool of the day seeking Adam Eve to stroll alongside.
Any time you read about God walking with people, whether it's Noah or Enoch or Abraham, throughout the Old Testament, particularly in this book of Genesis, what he realizes it is articulating a depth of relationship to God that we were always meant to have.
And yet he just said, I'm gonna be hidden from your face.
I will not have your presence.
I will not enjoy the comfort of your company.
You see sin
It costs him when it costs us.
It costs him everything.
That's why no matter how far you look or hard you search, no thing in this life will ever fulfill you.
It doesn't matter if you climb to the heights of corporate success or you sit in the halls of power or you become internet famous.
It'll never be enough for you.
Some of you, you're experiencing that right now.
Like you've arrived, achieved your dreams.
You're sitting at that table which you have longed to have a seat
And yet what you realize is, man, this is not what I thought it would be.
And the reason for that is you weren't designed to represent those things.
You were designed to represent God.
That's why no matter who you know or call friend in life, no one will ever satisfy you.
You can befriend billionaires, you can find the love of your life, you can put A-listers on speed dial, or you can serial date your way into the grave.
No one will ever be enough.
And the reason why is you weren't designed to relate to them, you were designed to relate to God.
And here's the thing, though our sin rightly deserves God's wrath, surprisingly, that's not the end of the story.
Because what we find in these final two verses is something that is truly unfair.
It says, then the Lord said to him,
Not so.
If anyone kills Cain, the vengeance shall be taken on him sevenfold.
And the Lord put a mark on Cain lest any who found him should attack him.
And then Cain went away from the presence of the Lord and settled in the land of naught east of Eden."
I'll wrap this point quick.
We can go ahead and have the band come back out and get ready.
As I was reading this and I was prepping for this time, what I realized is that this was the moment
within the entire story that truly felt most unfair to me.
Because what we see is that while Cain does nothing to deserve it, God offers him protection, a seal, a mark upon which he can be identified.
You see, what we realize in this story is that though he is deserving of God's wrath, he receives God's mercy.
And then it hit me why this was so shocking.
Because though God always gives sin what it deserves, He always offers us what we don't.
Though God always gives sin what it deserves, He always offers us what we don't.
And the reason why, for your fourth point, if you're taking notes, is because God's favor is never fair.
God's favor, it's never, ever fair.
How do I know that?
Because we see something so beautifully written upon these first few pages in the book of Genesis.
We see that it is God's heart not to take away life, but to give life.
That's all he does.
He just gives life over and over and over again.
And yet those who take life are us.
We're the ones guilty.
of robbing ourselves of the life that we long for, and yet God in his kindness, he, through Christ, he steps back into the story and he extends to us the life that we've wanted, the life that we've yearned for, yet we've never deserved.
He comes to give it and get the amazing thing about Jesus.
He doesn't just come to give you life, he comes to give you life abundantly.
You want to know why this story resonated so deeply with me?
I'll finish here.
Maybe you don't.
know this part of my personal story, but a key part of my personal story is I've struggled with self-hate for a very long time.
By God's grace, it's not something that I really wrestle with much any longer.
I've got to keep it in check and yet early days, particularly when I first got into ministry, I found that myself hate, it just ran rampant.
And the reason why is because just think about the world we live in.
We live in this digital age where you can look to the left and the right.
You can compare how you measure up in comparison to everybody else.
And yet as I was doing that, I was realizing, man, I don't just want to be liked by other people.
I'm like Cain.
I want to be preferred.
I want to be better.
I want to be best.
And as I evaluated that within my own story, what I saw was this.
Live from the enemy that I thought God only had so much favor to give, and yet by God's grace through His Spirit in the person of Christ I learned.
When I'm praying you would learn tonight, He is full of inexhaustible riches.
He is favored to give without end.
And the reason we know it is we can look to the cross and we can see He's done it.
He has afforded anyone and everyone that would place their faith in Christ the kind of favor they were never worthy of receiving.
For in Christ, what we know is that where we focus too much on what we do deserve and too little on what God deserves, Christ came and He did the opposite.
He looked upon those that deserve nothing and He considered them.
We're favored for somebody else, doesn't mean disfavor for us.
What we see in Jesus is our favor before God meant Jesus' disfavor and death.
Where God always gives sin what it deserves, we see in Christ the undeserving enduring the wrath on RBF.
And where God's favor isn't fair, you find Jesus.
For in Him and in Him alone, you find the favor which you seek.
Do you know Him?
Do you want Him?
He knows you and He wants you.
These come that you might receive the favor that you have so long looked for in this world.
Let me pray that you would find it in him.
God, thanks for tonight.
Thank you for these friends and this time and the chance to open up your word.
God, I just believe you're speaking to us, man.
I think you're speaking to us.
It's not God that you are seldom speaking.
It's that we're seldom listening.
It's not God that you don't know the way to our heart.
It's a God.
We don't know how to open it.
And so God, I'm beckoning you.
Please, O God,
move in my friends in a material way.
Let this no longer be something that we just intellectually understand.
Let it be something God that we experientially know, something God that's the very core of our being.
We get that Christ is not a concept.
He's a person and he's not far off, but he's come near and that he does not condemn.
He's come to say
And all we must do is not measure ourselves up, but place our faith in you for the smile of heaven.
It is raining upon those that cannot earn it, but will receive it.
And so God, we here tonight say, we want your favor, God, not favor as the world deems favor, but the delight of a father that looks upon us and says, I accept you.
I love you.
I want you forever.
You're not placed your faith in Him.
It's as easy as saying, I get it now, Jesus.
I see you now clearly.
And it's you that I want, you and you alone offer what I've not found elsewhere.
So won't you and you alone give me what it is I desire?
Won't you give me life and life abundantly?
God, we want to respond to you.
We don't want to race away.
We want to respond to you.
We don't want to rise, do our feet, and we want to respond to you.
We want to lift our hands.
We want to respond to you.
We want to come down to the altar.
We want to pray.
We want to respond to you.
We want to come and pray with the team that's here at the front, expressing our sin, confessing our problems and knowing God that that too is a response to you because God, you and you alone, you and you alone are worthy of responding to.
And so God, let us not consider what it is that's happening around us or what it is that others think of us, let us consider.
What is it you've done to us and what it is God that we think of you.
We stand to you and we pray and praise right now in Christ's name.
Amen.